I thought the rife would be noisier, but the new programs of the Atelier Robin
often have no sound is this normal. Yes, so the difference with the Atelier Robin and the
true rife at least one difference is with the Atelier Robin you could run the harmonics with it.
So most of the new, most of the programming that I have created with the Atelier Robin
is written in harmonics. I wrote all the programs of the Atelier Robin.
So if it's running a harmonic in the program that you're running, often there'll be no sound whatsoever
compared to the true rife, which could be loud at different times, especially running a lower
frequency. The Atelier Robin you could have sound at different times if you're running a lower
frequency that's not in a harmonic, but typically if you're running a harmonic you're going to have
very little to no sound. So yes, that is normal.